so here's matto matto's story on what
happened isn't matter supposed to be
like their Superstar it doesn't matter
like MSNBC Superstar yes Tyler would you
say yes or no like that's their
Superstar yeah I've never watched MSN
MSNBC replacing matter with previously
cancel Alex Wagner puzzles and Setters
no institutional memory msmc Alex wagon
has racial matters time slot replacement
for four days a week the Network's
biggest star is not on the air but
insiders have questioned why Executives
would attempt to replace Mata with a
previously canceled host who never moved
the needle on television MSNBC finished
the second quarter of 2022 with its
smallest audience amongst advertisement
demographic of adults ages 25 to 54
since 2003 Ms embassies nearly two
decades low in the critical category
came during a jam-packed stretch of news
that included Russia's ongoing invasion
of Ukraine the Uvalde Texas school
shooting in the beginning of the January
6 committee hearings the second quarter
also featured madout scaling back her
workload to once a week as she began
hosting The Rachel Maddow Show only on
Monday nights last month NBC selected
Wagner as a former NBC MSNBC host to
replace this matter
with a new program at 9 pm since Eastern
Eastern time slot Tuesdays through
Friday beginning in August what do you
think MSNBC is going through right now
as Adam said I don't pay much attention
to MSNBC but they're they're
I think everybody's trying to redirect
man they see Tucker Carlson has the
leading audience across cable television
not just in Republicans and Democrats as
well and they understand that people
have their numbers CNN MSNBC
all those Outlets are trying to revamp
and redirect themselves I think MSNBC is
tired of being the crazy Joy read Rachel
Maddow Network and they want to do
something different now I'd like to give
Rachel Maddow some credit we saw the
other day uh we played the clip about
her you know saying Trump never cited
this Insurrection so credit where credit
is due but I think I think people want
to get more of the Jake Tapper Vibe
where yes you may be opinionated but at
least you're rational coherent you can
make an argument you can fault your own
side etc etc you're not an activist
you're just reporting the news yeah you
have your biases which we all do but
like right there Pat when they said that
two decade low happened during a
jam-packed stretch of Ukraine uh uh in
the beginning of the January 6th
committee nobody wants to hear that [ __ ]
Bro nobody it's just too much it's like
you know threat to democracy I don't
know how many times I heard threat to
democracy over and over and like people
are just tired and don't forget they're
the same people that told you there was
rushing exactly that's where I was going
yeah that's why people know that they
hired the former producer from ABC News
to literally produce the first week of
this trial they know it's a it's a show
trial Tom what do you think is going on
here I I think MSNBC has got to find
itself and there's there's two thoughts
that are in the mind of leadership and
that they can't reconcile one is they
honestly feel they're a liberal position
that work they feel they are equal time
that's what they feel and that's why
they filled it with Rachel Maddow who
became a hit and so many things with it
the other side of it they're looking at
the reality of Tucker Carlson the
reality of moderates the reality of
ratings and they're also looking at the
reality of corporate ownership and they
are trapped they're trapped between the
identity of what they feel MSNBC is and
the ratings and the need for commercial
decisions and they're stuck in the
middle and you're seeing them trying you
know
trying to do it trying to put together
who's the right person for MSNBC right
now like if MSNBC was to go out there
and get somebody who would be a good
person I think the problem that MSC is
having is those right people have
already left um who am I talking about
Brian Williams I thought was an absolute
stud gone remember
of course said this is not what I signed
up for basically that's exactly right I
was in big Brian Williams fan I was also
a fan of what was the name Chris
Matthews been on the air forever and he
got caught up in the metoo Scandal what
have you what happened with him
um and MSNBC much like CNN jumped on the
anti-trump train now that the train is
off the tracks what's your story now
you're not going to start defending
Biden so they went all in on the
anti-trump uh you know campaign Trump's
gone you quote on quote one remember on
CNN but Don Lemon cried I don't care
okay now what no I mean you gotta still
be journalists and tell the news and
tell the stories and the facts and their
the facts aren't pretty right now do you
know sauce talks money zero sarcasm here
do you know sauce cast when you do a
sauce cast you have more viewers than
Don Lemon does
seriously no no well you're laughing
seriously you have
the same amount of viewers as Don Lemon
does think about that when you're doing
a YouTube live you're getting the same
amount of viewers as a Don Lemon is
getting how are they selling
advertisement on Don lemon's show how
are they selling it like what are you
telling people to do yeah are you like
who's watching that show in the first
place with Don Lemon so anyways if I'm
MSNBC if I'm any of these big guys you
gotta go be heavy duty recruiting today
and bring a new vision in that's
exciting and you really gotta fire the
bottom thirty percent of people that are
hurting these numbers and show the
marketplace that you're MSNBC everybody
knows your brand but your take you've
taken the wrong angle again pedaling
trying to you know please everybody and
you're trying to make everybody happy
didn't work out maybe a new strategy is
a good place to start right now well
because if they keep going the way
they're going right now they're going to
get crushed even more well there's a
case study for you and it's CNN bringing
Jeff sucker say bring in Jeff sucker he
strategically built exactly what he
wanted to build and he was not uh
inhibited in any way now he screwed
himself up with the whole Affair thing
and the thing that went over the you
know that the marketing because that was
a lack of integrity
but what he built was what he said he
would build it just didn't sell the
product didn't sell are you talking
about CNN correct and CNN plus so you
need to start at the top you need to
bring someone in and set the strategy
and go and if America doesn't like that
product they're not going to watch it
but that's where it's got to go it's not
going to be could we pay Tucker Carlson
a trillion dollars to come across the
street and say we're going to do it you
don't start it at that level you have to
do it the way CNN did and bring in
leadership to set strategy and to put it
there and if America doesn't like what's
there as they didn't like it with Jeff
then his affair and everything becomes
an excuse to also put a nail on him well
seeing they CNN CNN and MSNBC should
pray to God that Trump wins so they'll
have they could go back to the talking
center right then they'll get there I'm
dead seriously very good they better
pray to God that he wins again so they
could be like all right the Trump trains
back on the [ __ ] track and let's just
bash them every day oh interest that's
all they're going to do about so
everybody that's there better pray to
God because that's right Mark Zucker had
it was the Trump shot all those
undercover a project Veritas videos
those guys are like bro that's all they
told us to do was Trump trump it worked
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]